- Yeah, this is my truck
- Dernière vérification
avant le départ.
Il s'agit de s'assurer que
la trousse de premiers soins
est complète et fonctionnelle.
- TXA, that's your blood
clotter. That's ketamine.
- Un outil essentiel
pour les hospitaliers,
le bataillon médical dont
fait partie Brandon Mitchell.
Ancien militaire canadien,
originaire du NouveaBrBrunswick,
Brandon est, depuis un an,
engagé volontaire au sein
des forces ukrainiennes.
En 12 mois, il a été
de toutes les batailles,
sur tous les fronts,
mais sans jamais
tuer qui que ce soit.
Et s'il n'a jamais
pris de vies, il estime
en avoir sauvé quelques-unes.
La guerre vient avec
son lot de risques; Brandon
l'a rapidement compris.
Pour donner un sens
à sa mission, il s'est mis
à documenter son quotidien
dans autant de vidéos
devenues très populaires
sur les réseaux sociaux.
- Get ready to get out.
- Yeah, we're...
- And I'll turn around.
Go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go!
I'll turn around.
Go, go, go, go!
Comme cette fois
où son véhicule
a roulé sur une mine.
(explosions)
(cri)
- Oh my God! My God!
(bips de censure)
Oh my God!
I'm alive! I'm alive!
Get my med...
Bilan : une commotion cérébrale
et une perte d'audition.
Maisalalgré le danger,
le Canadien est convaincu
d'être à sa place en Ukraine.
Aujourd'hui, Brandon
considère l'armée ukrainienne
mmmme sa deuxième famille.
Surtout les hommes
de la 28e brigade
du 3e bataillon mécanisé,
à qui il rend régulièrement
visite dans leur bunker,
10 mètres sous terre, à
proximité de la ligne de front.
Ses vidéos lui ont permis
d'amasser des fonds.
Aussitôt utilisés pour
acheter des radios encptptés
et des génératrices pour
ses frères d'armes.
- Pablo Escobar...
(rires)
- Aujourd'hui, partout où il va,
Brandon se fait aborder
dans la rue par des soldats
reconnaissants qui souhaitent
le remercier pour sa générosité.
Parce qu'il a fait sienne
cette guerre, Brandon
n'imagine pas quitter
l'Ukraine avant la victoire.
En espérant vivre asse
longtemps et sans être
gravement blessé pour fêter
avec ses compagnons d'armes
le jour de la libération.
(tintement de cloche